I have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine to david p I've been a
while since we heard from homeless
Darrell now Pat you might not know about
homeless Darrell homeless daryl is a guy
also known as Darrell in a ditch Darrell
in a field scrub okie Darrell diabetic
Daryl Daryl has any number of names
quite literally and he used to Collin
pretty frequently hasn't called in for a
while cannabis is an issue that is very
important to scrub okie Darrell and that
motivated him to call in and check in
with us let's take a listen David great
shows always and it looks like things
are still looking up um hello I'm glad
to hear you're reporting in cannabis and
that you're boarding pro-cannabis but i
wish you would use the word marijuana it
has negative connotations yeah the
better preferred nomenclature is
cannabis please thank you bye yeah no
prob it's you know it's always great to
hear from Daryl even if it is a critique
but that's a common thing where people
say David you should be you should give
more legitimacy to cannabis by calling
it cannabis instead of marijuana I think
there's something to that but it just it
comes out naturally for me to say
marijuana yeah I never even heard of
this critique and as long as you're
you're using with the J and not an H the
word marijuana I think you're good yeah
the H is uh does that refer back to
reefer madness era yeah I think it's
pretty antiquated at this point they
probably didn't want to use that
seemingly Hispanic way of pronouncing it
Oh interesting I didn't even think of
that uh that angle but yeah and I know
exactly what you're saying okay good to
hear from Daryl always good to hear from
on the bonus show today we will talk
about why is work being fetishized in a
way at least in some industries in the
United States number two there is a fast
food chain that is combined fried
chicken and pizza they call it cheats uh
it sounds vile we will talk about that
and also Twitter is laying off nearly
ten percent of its workforce and I have
some thoughts about Twitter and I know
our audience does as well so we will
talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show please please
please don't miss the bonus show our
paid subscribers are so important to the
success in future of the show that every
day we create an additional
just for our paid subscribers so please
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership it'll feel great believe me
uh and you will get access instant
access to the bonus show the commercial
free TV show and so many other great
member benefits